j'envoie des punchline que personne
alors de bouffon ça vous fait marrer
sachez que j'ai peut-être péchenard ou
thomas calabro dit vous allez tous vous
présentez aura prénom nana non montiel
je passe mon temps chez point soleil
ares ne m'a pas quand on regarde je
passe mon temps chez point soleil je
veux qu'on me respecte quand meme macro
parce que moi face mais réchaud h et les
maquereaux un exploit dans sa lite est
gelée gars n'ont pas vu d'ici je fais la
télé je suis pas inquiet mais je vais
pas calculer si tu commences à mi
[Applaudissements]
hauteur de l'articulation mais ovi sache
que je suis un champion aux gens voient
des punchline que personne alors de
bouffon ça vous fait marrer
sachez que j'ai peut-être péchenard au
thorax
[Applaudissements]
si bas et regarder chez maxim gainey tu
vas te retrouver bientôt comme un génie
si tu te frotte à moi tu devrais à la
tête d'orange tu vas te dit que tu étais
avec les ajustements je tire des baskets
que bell a dit parker
attention attention tu les connais par
coeur c'est pas la chandeleur moi je
suis naïf car aujourd'hui c'est la
fonderie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai pas parlé
celles et ceux qui critiquent je le
prends tu enlèves les jockeys
et l'autre à lectra au bon sens la
nouvelle on attend j'arrive plus fort
qu'un coup de maillet bull pas pigé
loulou j'arrive plus fort qu'un coup de
maillet poule où andrine faisaient tout
ce boulot c'est toulouse
ouais ouais j'suis désolé en fait son
métier
ça a été beaucoup n'ont pas besoin qu'on
fasse des caisses gege plus devant qu'un
ouragan
ouais ça me fait rire je le confesse
appelle-moi benji l'odorant vieux way
répondu oui au nom de bella je lance des
sons
même si tu ne me crois pas c'est l'avis
de m la stat du hadj il fait le jeu
n'est pas bavard il m'a bien assez ils
voulaient message
mais moi je ne voulais pas
oui je sais vous m'appelez mamie ces
photos auraient péri mais qu'elle est
black de gens mis mon nom c'est mourir
et je vous cache autant comme les flancs
et ronnie ash ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]